[Música]
[Aplausos]
choco carache nuevos bonos en google ni
malas noticias a ni nadie que cuatro con
el padre y con microchip existe cada vez
en cabo march y ves a tu madre es una
tarea y ojivas
muy pocas veces solemos pensar el tiempo
más allá de nuestra dimensión de nuestra
existencia de alguna manera la capacidad
de poder ver como el ser humano y la
humanidad ha transcurrido su vida hasta
ahora y como cada uno de sus aportes ha
sido fundamental para nuestras nuestras
existencias hoy quizás ha sido una una
parte muy fundamental que buscamos la
necesidad de que se reflexione porque
cuando observamos el tiempo más allá de
lo que podemos garantizar a partir de
nuestra existencia nos damos cuenta que
cada una de las construcciones humanas
ha sido fundamental hoy para que me
escuchen para que conversemos para que
incluso compartamos en este momento un
mismo idioma de dónde venimos cómo nos
constituimos humanamente cómo llegamos
hasta acá cómo es que tenemos estos
conocimientos y cómo han permanecido en
el tiempo y en la existencia por más que
humanamente también hayan existido
difíciles u hostiles
cuando hablamos sobre los conocimientos
también tenemos que comprender que
humanamente estamos dejando una huella
en el universo y en la existencia de la
humanidad por cada una de estas
creaciones que nos hemos atrevido a
hacer este conocimiento que nos hemos
atrevido a transformar pero sobre todo
que hemos logrado heredar a las
siguientes generaciones
yo estoy hoy aquí porque soy heredera de
una cultura milenaria mi cultura está
chicken y soy parte de uno de los 22
pueblos mayas que aún existimos y
estamos vivos en este territorio que
ahora llaman guatemala solo ahora en
este territorio existimos 25 pueblos
distintos que desafortunadamente no
hemos aprendido a ver con otros ojos ni
hemos logrado aún botar esas barreras
que nos dividen y nos siguen viendo como
entre otros y otros nunca como nosotros
y nosotras
recuerdo que cuando fui a la escuela una
de las primeras cosas que bueno de las
que no olvido tampoco
fue una manera en que me cambió la vida
al insertar me a un mundo completamente
distinto al mío a mi cultura caciquil
hablar en otro idioma pensar en otro
idioma entender la vida de otra manera
que es la riqueza que nos permiten los
idiomas esas estructuras de pensamiento
que nos permiten trasladarnos a otros
mundos
al encontrarme en un nuevo sistema una
de las primeras cosas que me enseñaron
fue que la indumentaria de los pueblos
originarios no nos pertenecía a nosotras
ni a nosotros se hablaba entonces de que
pertenecía aunque era parte de un
uniforme colonial que había sido
impuesto a los pueblos para uniformar
los y para que entonces aquellos
administradores de los pueblos de indios
también identificarán que comunidades
estaban azúcar
nunca nos enseñaron en la escuela por
más que mi comunidad en su mayoría hasta
hoy somos así que les
nunca nos dijeron que pertenecíamos a
culturas que habían trascendido más allá
de seis mil años de historia y que
existen pruebas materiales hasta hoy que
indican que está permanencia de los
pueblos es fundamental para mantener la
riqueza cultural de este país tampoco
nos dijeron que existen cientos de
restos aún materiales que permanecen por
miles de años y que la indumentaria
quien se está parte de nuestra cultura
quien materializa nuestra nuestra
identidad y nuestra manera de entender
el mundo y de querer vivir la vida se ha
documentado y ha encontrado distintas
maneras para existir hasta hoy y que el
proceso para resguardarlo y para que
ustedes lo vean en mí en esta noche no
ha sido un proceso sencillo para los
pueblos ha sido una lucha por la
identidad la que es principalmente las
mujeres mayas llevamos hoy en este país
para mantener nuestras culturas para
transmitir nuestros idiomas y para
trasladar
conocimiento que es único en la
humanidad que es el arte de tejer y de
bordar y no solo es tejer por tejer sino
es guardar historia hacer lienzos de
identidad que permanecen cuya técnica es
una ciencia que ha implicado
conocimiento científico pero que también
ha implicado una lucha para nosotras
para que se mantenga hasta ahora
encontramos por ejemplo en este proceso
que hemos tenido que emprender distintas
generaciones de mujeres de todo el país
hemos ido recolectando la información
con la que nosotros garantizamos que
nuestra cultura nuestras cultura es
permanente y que estamos vivas y que
somos descendientes de esos mayas
milenarios que solo desafortunadamente
que únicamente ubicamos como tikal por
ejemplo pero que muy pocas veces hemos
abierto nuestras mentes para entender la
riqueza que permanece en estos
territorios
en este proceso de brindar herramientas
también para las generaciones jóvenes
para que comprendan de dónde de dónde
venimos y por qué es importante mantener
la identidad compartimos como códices
vasijas figurillas dinteles y cientos de
restos materiales muestran como en estos
territorios ha habido una actividad de
castil que es un arte y una ciencia
textil que ha durado más de 6000 años
una de las deidades principales existen
a la que se le relaciona directamente
con el tejido y con la fertilidad una
deidad femenina que además posiciona
también como antiguamente
éramos concebida en las mujeres otra
sintonía y otra manera muy distinta a la
que tenemos que enfrentar hoy a pesar de
que somos la población mayoritaria que
persiste en este país podemos ver como
intel en la representación entre la vida
y la muerte está tejiendo en un telar
malla de cintura como en su mano
sostiene una aguja que es la aguja con
la que todavía cada una de estas
herramientas persiste cuando se hace un
textil cuando se hace un huipil una faja
auto collar un corte que se hacen
también con telares de cintura malla y
podemos ver incluso sobre el para en el
que está puesto su telar y esta imagen
pertenece al códice maya que se
encuentra en madrid
hemos encontrado también y es la
información que queremos que transforme
nuestra manera que observamos lo que se
construye y lo que se está creando en
este país encontramos distinta
simbología sobre el papel que ha tenido
la mujer sobre su vinculación con los
tejidos y con las creaciones
identitarias que vamos guardando en cada
uno de nuestros textiles que como dije
hace un momento son lienzos encontramos
también entre las tumbas y las ofrendas
y los altares material que muestra como
no sólo sabíamos armar y los siempre
tejer hilos también sabíamos producir la
materia prima uno de los principales
problemas que enfrentamos las tejedoras
son 6 lava se producía en algodón y
podemos ver las herramientas que se
utilizaba para este proceso de hilado
agujas para tejer que tienen motivos de
animales acuáticos elaborados en huesos
de animales y que persisten hoy en la
elaboración de los tejidos que hacemos
en guatemala los pueblos mayas
encontramos de intel
en donde las mujeres y mujeres y hombres
visten indumentaria de distintas formas
con distintos símbolos que permanecen en
nuestros huipiles y los son únicamente
símbolos porque si es nuestro entorno
que se ha ido guardando en cada pedazo
de tejido que es una manera de guardar
la historia podemos observar incluso
como nuestras antepasadas lograron
observar las constelaciones y guardar
eso y expresarla en sus tejidos como
podemos verlo en este wiki liu que se
ubica en san mateo estatal una cultura
milenaria junto con todos los demás
pueblos mayas que existimos podemos ver
simbología que permanecen en huipiles
que se utilizan día a día y que incluso
en este momento mientras que yo hablo
con ustedes cientos de mujeres
permanecen y siguen ahora a estas horas
de la noche tejiendo en sus casas para
poder también vivir de esta actividad
textil y que es uno de los motivos
también por los que estoy acá para
compartir con ustedes que nuestras
creadas
o creaciones únicas como lo ha de ser
cualquier creación de cualquier cultura
en el mundo que cada una de estas
creaciones aportan a la humanidad que
contiene en ciencia tecnología pero que
sobre todo hemos sido guardiana de un
derecho que es nuestro derecho a la
identidad de la cultura y que queremos
compartir con los otros pueblos para que
los vean con otros ojos que no son
uniformes coloniales que son creaciones
colectivas que son creaciones que han
tardado miles de años que representan
nuestras culturas lo que somos y lo que
sentimos que hay dentro de estos lienzos
símbolos que van más allá de los cielos
son manera antes de trasladar la forma
en que pensamos la dualidad por ejemplo
que es una parte de lo que remarcamos
acá en este wifi así que le santiago
sacatepéquez en el que podemos ver
las figuras de la luna y el sol pero
claramente concebido en otra manera para
expresarlos en estos lienzos que son lo
que seguimos construyendo en nuestras
comunidades que trabajo de tejer y de
bordar implica semanas horas y días o
meses incluso para ser elaborado que
implica una gran concentración que
implica habilidad matemática que implica
un conocimiento y una ciencia podemos
observar como todo como es como es todo
un proceso de producción que se ha
generado a partir del conocimiento de
cientos y miles de mujeres de nuestra
historia y que es la mejor herencia que
estamos dejando para las nuevas
generaciones nuestras culturas
que las mujeres mayas estamos ahora
posicionándonos como una lucha
generacional también para que se nos
observe de otra manera pero que también
para dejarles una idea
y que por eso es necesario y por eso
hemos planteado la necesidad de que este
país comprenda nuestro planteamiento
acerca de la protección de la propiedad
intelectual colectiva de los pueblos
indígenas eso significa una protección
legal de las creaciones que
milenariamente los pueblos hemos
trabajado hasta hoy y que hemos sido las
únicas y los únicos guardianes siendo
las mujeres principalmente las que
mantenemos la actividad textil y que
guatemala se sostiene económicamente en
una gran parte por el turismo que viene
a este país para venir a ver nuestras
culturas y que también un gran aporte ha
sido a las artesanías desafortunadamente
lo que crean los pueblos lo que nosotras
y nosotros hacemos es considerada como
artesanía y no como arte hasta um
y es a este desnivel de categorías sigue
haciendo que actualmente los pueblos
vivamos la apropiación de nuestras
creaciones que se falte respeto a
nuestras comunidades porque no hay una
consulta sobre lo que se hace o no con
su patrimonio textil y que hasta hoy las
mujeres indígenas tejedoras sean las que
son mal las mal pagadas en todo este
sistema en el que se vende y se compran
textiles lo que se comercializa hay
textiles que se venden en el mercado por
ser usados hasta cinco por cinco
quetzales mientras que hemos visto en
mercados internacionales que
transformados o ensamblados en otros
productos son vendidos hasta por mil
quetzales o por mil dólares en el
extranjero
tenemos un le estamos llamando la
cultura del regateo a algo que no
debería ser cultural que es una mala
práctica que no está valorando el
conocimiento y lo que el trabajo de las
mujeres aporta es un conocimiento
científico y estamos haciendo las
mujeres nos estamos organizando para que
también compartamos estas ideas no nos
oponemos a la comercialización pero es
necesario abrir procesos justos y
equilibrados que nos permitan ganar
también a los pueblos indígenas
que valore el trabajo de las mujeres que
se vea el arte y la ciencia que estamos
creando y manteniendo hasta hoy
actualmente existe ya formado un consejo
de tejedoras que es una organización
local ya que cuenta con un acuerdo
municipal en el que fue declarado a la
indumentaria de santiago sacatepéquez
como patrimonio textil de la comunidad
siguiente santiago sacatepéquez esto
implica y ya hay una manera de
organización a la que se le pueden
consultar sobre lo que se desea hacer
con su indumentaria para respetar las
culturas que estamos vivas y para que a
través de este tipo de organización
comunitaria se pueda hacer una
intermediación entre las empresas y las
comunidades porque estamos dispuestos a
dialogar y porque los pueblos mayas
hemos compartido nuestros conocimientos
durante miles de años lo que estamos
pidiendo es respeto a nuestras
creaciones y que haya una protección y
que se observe que esta es una riqueza
que le pertenece a un país completo
hemos también logrado que la corte de
constitucionalidad se pronuncie a favor
de las tejedoras del país diciendo que
no hay una ley específica que resguarde
la propiedad intelectual colectiva que
es otra sintonía porque son creaciones
que no le pertenecen a una sola persona
son creaciones comunitarias que fueron
construidas por cientos y miles de años
y que son una herencia cultural que le
pertenecen a los pueblos y que tenemos
derecho a la identidad pero que también
tenemos derecho a transmitir esa
identidad y que el estado también
debería de ser parte de esa protección
para que esto permanezca de apostamos al
conocimiento al diálogo y al compartir
ideas para que podamos también ser parte
de esta construcción en el que estamos
replanteando cómo es que normalizamos
incluso el racismo y cómo volvimos
verdades estereotipos que se
construyeron muy mal intencionadamente
en la historia pero que ya es momento de
cambiar como llamarle traje típico por
ejemplo a nuestro
los 22 pueblos mayas distintos con
idiomas distintos con indumentarias
distintas con maneras de entender la
vida distintas y llamar traje típico ha
sido una manera de desvalorizar toda
esta creación mil arana que portamos y
que mantenemos hoy estamos hablando de
posicionar con su idioma el de español
que es una indumentaria que significa
más allá de un pedazo de tela significa
cultura identidad e historia y que
mantener nuestra ropa hasta hoy ha sido
un proceso les invito a leer que
seguramente ustedes ya tienen
conocimiento de eso los documentos donde
se narraba o donde muchos de los
religiosos los primeros que fueron
llegando a estos territorios fueron
narrando como encontradas vestidas a las
personas mientras llegaban y como ese
ese mito acerca de que estábamos de
taparrabos y que sabemos que sólo los
animales tienen rabo es precisamente eso
ha sido un mito y que ya no podemos
seguir creyendo y normalizando esas
prácticas discriminatorias
que hay una gran herencia que queremos
compartir que la conozcan y que estamos
peleando en el sentido de luchar por
nuestra identidad por expresarle al país
nuestras demandas culturales y es la
primera vez en la historia de este país
que en las cortes se planteó una demanda
cultural que es la consolidación de la
figura de la propiedad intelectual
colectiva quien soy parte del movimiento
nacional de tejedoras lucha física en la
bomba que junto con afe es la asociación
femenina para el desarrollo de
sacatepéquez junto con mujeres tejedoras
de todo el país de distintas profesiones
estamos planteando porque somos las
hijas de las abuelas que no moverían
porque ellas viven en el universo de
nuestros tejidos y porque nuestros
tejidos son los lienzos que la colonia
no pudo
[Música]